memory is such an everyday thing that we
almost take it for granted we'll
remember what we had for breakfast this
morning or what we did last weekend it's
only when memory starts to fail that we
appreciate just how amazing it is and
how much we allow our past experiences
to define us but memory is not always a
good thing as the American poet and
clergyman John Lancaster Spaulding once
said as memory may be a paradise from
which we cannot be driven it may also be
a hill from which we cannot escape many
of us experience chapters of our lives
that we would prefer to never have
happened it's estimated that nearly 90%
of us will experience some sort of
traumatic event during our lifetimes
many of us will suffer acutely following
these events and then recover maybe even
become better people because of those
experiences but some events are so
extreme and that many up to half of
those who survived sexual violence for
example we're go on to develop
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
PTSD is a debilitating mental health
condition characterized by symptoms such
as intense fear and anxiety and
flashbacks of the traumatic event these
symptoms have a huge impact on a
person's quality of life and are often
triggered by particular situations or
cues in that person's environment the
responses to those cues may have been
adaptive when they were first learned
fear in diving for cover in a war zone
for example but in PTSD they continue to
control behavior when it's no longer
appropriate if a combat veteran returns
home and is diving for cover when he or
she hears a car backfiring or can't
leave their own home because of intense
anxiety then the responses those cues
those memories have become what we would
refer to
as maladaptive in this way we can think
of PTSD as being a disorder of
maladaptive memory now I should stop
myself here because I'm talking about
memory as if it's a single thing it
isn't there are many different types of
memory and these depend upon different
circuits and regions within the brain as
you can see there are two major
distinctions in our types of memory
there are those memories that we're
consciously aware of where we know we
know and that we can pass on in words
this would include memories for facts
and events because we can declare these
memories we refer to these as
declarative memories the other type of
memory is non-declarative these are
memories where we often don't have
conscious access to their content of
those memories and that we can't pass on
in words the classic example of a
non-declarative memory is the motor
skill for riding a bike now this being
Cambridge the odds are that you can ride
a bike you know what you're doing on two
wheels but if I asked you to write me a
list of instructions that would teach me
how to ride a bike as my four-year-old
son did when we bought him a bike for
his last birthday you would really
struggle to do that how should you sit
on the bike so you're balanced how fast
you need to pedal so you're stable if a
gust of wind comes at you which muscle
should you tense and by how much so that
you don't get blown off I'll be
staggered if you can give me the answers
to those questions but if you can ride a
bike you do have the answers you're just
not consciously aware of them getting
back to PTSD
another type of non-declarative memory
is emotional memory now this has a
specific meaning in psychology and
refers to our ability to learn about
cues in our environment and their
emotional and motivational significance
what do I mean by that well think of the
you know a cue like the smell of baking
bread or a more abstract cue like a 20
pound note because these cues have been
paired with good things in the past we
like them and we approach them other
cues like the buzzing of a wasp elicits
very negative emotions and some quite
dramatic avoidance behavior in some
people now I hate wasps I can tell you
that fact but what I can't give you are
the non-declarative emotional memories
for how I react when there's a wasp
nearby I can't give you the racing heart
the sweaty palms that sense of rising
panic I can describe them to you but I
can't pick them to you now importantly
from the perspective of PTSD stress has
very different effects on declarative
and non declarative memories and the
brain circuits and regions supporting
them emotional memory is supported by a
small almond shaped structure called the
amygdala and it's connections
declarative memory especially the what
where and when of event memory is
supported by seahorse shaped region of
the brain called the hippocampus the
extreme levels of stress experienced
during trauma have very different
effects on these two structures as you
can see as you increase a person's level
of stress from not stressful to slightly
stressful the hippocampus acting to
support the event memory increases in
its activity and works better to support
the storage of that declarative memory
but as you increase to moderately
stressful intensely stressful and then
extremely stressful as would be found in
trauma the hippocampus effectively shuts
down this means that under the high
levels of stress hormones that are
experienced during trauma we are not
storing the details the specific details
of what where and when
now while stress is doing that for the
hippocampus look at what it does the
amygdala that structure important for
the emotional non-declarative memory its
activity gets stronger and stronger so
what this leaves us with in PTSD is an
overly strong emotional in this case
fear memory that is not tied to a
specific time or place because the
hippocampus is not
boring what where and when in this way
these cues can control behavior when
it's no longer appropriate and that's
how they become maladaptive so if we
know that PTSD is due to maladaptive
memories can we use that knowledge to
improve treatment outcomes for patients
with PTSD a radical new approach being
developed to treat post-traumatic stress
disorder aims to destroy those
maladaptive emotional memories that
underlie the disorder this approach has
only been considered a possibility
because of the profound changes in our
understanding of memory in recent years
traditionally it was thought that making
a memory was like writing in a notebook
in pen once the ink had dried you
couldn't change the information it was
thought that all those structural
changes that happen in the brain to
support the storage of memory were
finished within about six hours and
after that they were permanent this is
known as the consolidation view however
more recent research suggests that
making a memory is actually more like
writing in a word processor we initially
make the memory and then we save it or
store it but under the right conditions
we can edit that memory this
reconsolidation view suggests that those
structural changes that happen in the
brain to support memory can be undone
even for old memories now this editing
process isn't happening all the time it
only happens under very specific
conditions of memory retrieval so let's
consider memory retrievers being
recalling the memory or like opening the
file quite often we are simply
retrieving the memory we're opening the
file as read-only but under the right
conditions we can open that file in edit
mode and then we can change the
information in theory we could delete
the content of that file and when we
press save that is held then file the
memory persists
not only does this reconsolidation view
allow us to account for some of the
quirks of memory like how we all
sometimes miss remember the past it also
gives us a way to destroy those
maladaptive fear memories that underlie
PTSD all we would need would be two
things a way of making the memory
unstable opening that file in edit mode
and a way to delete the information
we've made the most progress with
working out how to delete the
information it was found fairly early on
that a drug widely prescribed to control
blood pressure in humans
abby's a blocker called propranolol
could be used to prevent the
reconsolidation of fear memories in rats
if propranolol was given while the
memory was in edit mode
rats behaved as if they were no longer
afraid of a frightening trigger - It was
as if they had never learned to be
afraid of vacuum and this was with a
drug that was safe for use in humans now
not long after that it was shown that
propranolol could destroy fear memories
in humans as well but critically it only
works if the memory is in edit mode now
that study was with healthy human
volunteers but it's important because it
shows that the rats findings can be
extended to humans and ultimately to
human patients and with humans
you can test whether destroying the
non-declarative emotional memory does
anything to the declarative event memory
and this is really interesting even
though people who were given propranolol
while the memory was in edit mode were
no longer afraid of that frightening
trigger - they could still describe the
relationship between the cue and the
frightening outcome it was as if they
knew they should be afraid and yet they
weren't this suggests that propranolol
can selectively target the
non-declarative emotional memory but
leave the declarative event memory
intact but critically propranolol can
only have any of
on the memory if it's in edit mode so
how do we make a memory unstable how do
we get it into edit mode or my own lab
has done quite a lot of work on this we
know that it depends on introducing some
but not too much new information to be
incorporated into the memory we know
about the different chemicals the brain
uses the signal that a memory should be
updated and the file edited now our work
is mostly in rats but other labs have
found the same factors allow memories to
be edited in humans even maladaptive
memories like those underlying PTSD in
fact a number of labs in several
different countries have begun
small-scale clinical trials of these
memory destroying treatments for PTSD
and have found really promising results
now these studies need replication on a
larger scale but they show the promise
of these memory destroying treatments
for PTSD
maybe trauma memories do not need to be
the hell from which we cannot escape now
although this memory destroying approach
holds great promise that's not to say
that it's straightforward or without
controversy is it ethical to destroy
memories what about things like
eyewitness testimony what if you can't
give someone propranolol because it
would interfere with other medicines
that they're taking well with respect to
ethics and eyewitness testimony I would
say the important point to remember is
the finding from that human study
because propranolol is only acting on
the non-declarative emotional memory it
seems unlikely that it would affect
eyewitness testimony which is based on
declarative memory essentially what
these memory destroying treatments are
aiming to do is to reduce the emotional
memory not get rid of the trauma memory
altogether this should make the
responses of those with PTSD more like
those who've been through trauma and not
developed PTSD than people who've never
experienced trauma in the first place I
think that most people would find that
more ethically acceptable than a
treatment that aim to create some sort
of spot
this mind what about prepare at all
you can't give foreign oral to everyone
and not everyone wants to take drugs to
treat mental health conditions well here
Tetris could be useful yes
Tetris working with clinical
collaborators we've been looking at
whether behavioral interventions can
also interfere with the reconsolidation
of memories now how would that work well
we know that it's basically impossible
to do two tasks at the same time if they
both depend on the same brain region for
processing think trying to sing along to
the radio while you're trying to compose
an email the processing for one
interferes with the other was the same
when you retrieve a memory especially in
edit mode if we take a highly visual
symptom like flashbacks in PTSD and get
people to recall the memory in edit mode
and then get them to do a highly
engaging visual tasks like playing
Tetris it should be possible to
introduce so much interfering
information into that memory that it
essentially becomes meaningless that's
the theory and it's supported by data
from healthy human volunteers now our
volunteers watched highly unpleasant
films so think I surgery row traffic
safety adverts Scorsese's the big shave
these Troma films produce something like
flashbacks in healthy volunteers for
about a week after viewing them we found
that getting people to recall those
memories the worst moments of those
unpleasant films and playing Tetris at
the same time massively reduced the
frequency of the flashbacks and again
the memory had to be in edit mode for
that to work now my collaborators have
since taken this to clinical populations
they've tested this in survivors of road
traffic accidents and mothers who've had
emergency cesarean sections both types
of trauma that frequently lead to PTSD
and they found really promising
reductions in symptoms in both of those
clinical cases so although
is still much to learn and procedures to
optimize these memory destroying
treatments hold great promise for the
treatment of mental health disorders
like PTSD
maybe trauma memories do not need to be
a hell from which we cannot escape I
believe that this approach should allow
those who want to to turn the page on
chapters of their lives that they would
prefer to never have experienced and so
improve our mental health thank you